[موسيقى]
جزاء الغيم تنهمر الحروف
لها نغم يحس به الشغوف
يرى فيها غصونا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوف
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
وسمعته يقول قفا لرئيس لا يجتمع الاخوان
على اخوانه ولا تقع الاجفان على جفانه
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
يقول الله تعالى في سوره الاعراف فانبجست
منه اثنتا عشره عينا وجاء في سوره البقره
قوله تعالى
فانفجرت منه اثنتا عشره عينا فما الفرق
بين فعلي انبجس وانفجر يقول الراغب
الاصفهاني بجس الماء وانبجس اي انفجر لكن
الانبس اكثر ما يقال فيما يخرج من شيء ضيق
والانفجار يستعمل فيما يخرج من شيء واسع
يقول تعالى وفجرنا خلالهما نهارا وقال
وفجرنا الارض عيوننا لم يستعمل فعل
الانبجاس هنا نظرا لعظمه الامر وقالوا
الانفجار الانشقاق والانبجياس اضيق منه
فيكون اولا انبجاسا ثم يصير انفجارا فيما
يتعلق بمثالي الاعراف والبقره يقول
استاذنا الدكتور فاضل السامرائي انفجرت
اولا وانبجست ثانيا انفجرت فخرج الماء
دفاقا غزيرا ثم قل الماء فناسبه لفظ
الانجاز لماذا قل بالمعاصي التي ارتكبها
بنو اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
ابن هرمه شاعر غزل اشتهر بالبخل على
ادعائه الكرم في شعره ذهب اليه قوما من
قريش يريدون العبث به فقال لهم ما جاء بكم
قالوا سمعنا شعرك فدعانا اليك لما سمعناك
تقول اغشى الطريق بقبه ورواقها واحل في
قلل الربى واقيموا ان امرا جعل الطريق
لبيته طنبا وانكر حقه للئيم فقال لهم ما
على الارض عصابه اضعف عقولا ولا اسخف دينا
منكم اما سمعتم الله تعالى يقول للشعراء
وانهم يقولون ما لا يفعلون افيخبركم الله
اني اقول ما لا افعل وتريدون مني ان افعل
ما اقول
[موسيقى]
بالعربيه المرجو بسكون الراء ارض واسعه
فيها نبت كثير ترعى فيها الدواب والمرج
بفتح الراء الابل ترعى بلا راع
والبكر بكسر الباء اول الولد يقال هذا بكر
ابويه اي اول ولد يولد لهما والبكر بفتح
الباء الفتي من الابل
سرق اعرابي نافجه مسك فقيل له ان كل من غل
ياتي بما غل يوم القيامه فقال اذا والله
احملها طيبه الريح خفيفه المحمل
هذا لص صاحب فكاهه
[موسيقى]
يقول المثل حميم المرء واصله فما قصه
المثل هذا مثل قديم يقال عندما يكون
الصديق اقرب الى المرء من قريبه لوقوفه
معه وقت الشده وللمثل حكايه وهي ان رجلا
يقال له كلاب بن فارع كان في غنم له
يحميها فهاجمه اسد ضار وجعل يحطمها فانبرى
كلاب يدافع عنها فحمل عليه الاسد فخبط
بمخالبه وجثم عليه فانكب كلاب على الارض
والاسد من فوقه وهو على هذه الحاله اذ مر
به رجلان الخنابر بن مره وكان من اقربائه
واخر يقال له حوشب فاستغاث بهما كلاب
فخذله قريبه وحاد عنه بين من برى الاخر
حوشب لمساعدته فلما هاجمه الاسد تمكن
بسيفه من صرعه فقام كلاب يقول يا حوشب انت
حبيبي وقريبي دون
وانطلق به الى قومه يخبرهم بذلك فلما هلك
كلاب بعد ذلك اختصم الرجلان الخنابر وحوشب
في ميراثه عند سيد القوم فقال حوشب انا
حميمه وقريبه فلقد خذلته ونصرته وقطعته
ووصلته وصممت عنه واجبته فلما شهد القوم
بذلك قال الخنابر حميم المرء واصله وقضى
لحوشب بالورث وصارت مثلا
[موسيقى]
قال ابن الورديه في لاميته في عدم جدوى
التفاخر بالانساب ما لم يقترن ذلك بالعلم
والعمل لا تقل اصلي وفصلي ابدا انما اصل
الفتاه ما قد حصل قد يسود المرء من دون اب
وبحسن السبك قد ينقذ دخل قيمه الانسان ما
يحسنه اكثر الانسان منه ام اقل وقال ابو
العتاهيه كن ابن من شئت واكتسب ادبا يغنيك
محموده عن النسب ان الفتاه من يقول ها انا
ذا ليس الفتى من يقول كان ابي وكان امير
الشعراء احمد شوقي يقول لا يقولن امرؤ
اصلي فما اصله مسك واصل الناس طين نسب
البدر او الشمس اذا جاء بالاباء مغمورا
رهين
وكنت احفظ ابياتا تقول لسنا وان احسابنا
كرمت يوما على الاحساء نتكل نبني كما كانت
اوائلنا تبني ونفعل فوق ما فعلوا
[موسيقى]
الحقيبه محشوكه بالكتب والكراسات والطعام
محشوك في فمه يقول عوامنا هذا فيحافظون
على المعنى الاصلي للحشك بلفظه الصحيح
ويقال حشكت الناقه اذا تركتها دون حلب
فتجمع لبنها فهي محشوكه
وحشك القوم اذا حشدوا وحشكت السحابه كثر
ماؤها ومنه قولهم للنخله الكثيره الحمل
حاشك وحشكت السماء اتت بمطرها
اتوقع ايضا ان المثل الشائع في الشام
يقولون ضربني حشك لك اي انه جمعني في مكان
او حصرني في زاويه وانهال علي ضربا تجمعت
فيه انواع العذاب
[موسيقى]
لا تقل اسفت لعدم مقابلتك بل قل اسفت على
عدم مقابلتك لان اسفه وما يشتق منه يتعدى
على وليس باللام للاسف هو المبالغه في
الحزن وهو ايضا التلهف والتحسر فكما يقال
حزنت على ما فات كذلك نقول اسفت على الشيء
قال ابن منظور اسف على ما فاته وتاسف اي
تلهف ونقول اسف عليه اسفا اي غضب غضبا ورد
في القاموس المحيط اسفه اغضبه وتاسف عليه
تلهف
لا تقل حن الغريب لوطنه بل قل حن الى وطنه
الفعل حنا بهذا المعنى يتعدى باله يقال حن
قلبي اليه بمعنى نزع وشتاق واما اذا قصد
بالحنين الصوت فجاء الفعل من غير جار
ومجرور نقول حنت الابل ورد في لسان العرب
حنين الابل على معنيين حنينها صوتها اذا
اشتاقت الى ولدها وحنينها نزعها الى ولدها
من غير صوت
لا تقل قابلت المسؤولين عن بكره ابيهم بل
قل قابلت المسؤولين على بكره ابيهم ورد في
لسان العرب جاءت هوازن على بكره ابيها
يريدون بهذه الكلمه الكثره ووفره العدد
وانهم جاؤوا جميعا لم يتخلف منهم احد
[موسيقى]
قيل لاعرابي ما اسم المرق عندكم قال
السخين قالوا فاذا برد قال لا ندعه يبرد
روى الحصري في كتابه جمع الجواهر في الملح
والنوادر قال كان جامع ابن وهب الصيدلاني
اكثر الناس دينا واعظمهم غفله اشترى مره
ثلجا كثيرا فقيل له انه كثير قال اريد ان
امصه وارمي بثفله قال وسقطت ابنته في بئر
فقال يا بني لا تبرحي حتى اجيء بمن يخرجك
ومن طرائف القدماء ان لصا دخل على ابن ابي
قيس ففتش البيت فما وجد شيئا يسرق فلما
اراد ان يخرج قال ابو قيس اغلق الباب خلفك
فقال له اللص من كثره ما اخذت حتى
تستخدمني
[موسيقى]
كنت قد سالتكم في تويتر ماذا قال الشعراء
في الوداع الحقيقه ان هذا السؤال تراك مت
تحته انواع من الجواهر والدرر الجميله
تبدت في مشاركاتكم التي استعرضها الان
استاذنا عارف حجاوي شارك معنا ببيت رائع
البيت هذا اول مره اسمعه يقول وينتابني
عند الوداع ذهول كما عاش بين الطعنتين
قتيل
وهذا البيت الرائع فيه تكثيف
لصوره
يموت فيها المودع ثم يحيى ثم يموت ثم يحيى
ياسمين تقول ودع الصبره محب ودعك ذائع من
سره ما استودعك يقرع السن على ان لم يكن
زاد في تلك الخطى اذ شيعك الابيات الشهيره
الرائعه ايضا لابن زيدون
مشاركه من الحسن المشهوري يقول استودعوا
الله في بغداد لي قمرا بالكرخ في فلك
الازرار مطلعه ودعته وبودي لو يودعني صفو
الحياه واني لا اودعه
هذه قصيده ابن زريق طبعا نوال تقول بكت
عيني غداه البين دمعا واخرى بالبكاء بخلت
علينا
فعاقبت التي بالدمع ضنت بان اغمضتها يوم
التقينا
احمد بن مطر يقول الا ان الوداع هو البلاء
فهلك من مواجعه شفاء وكم لك الوداع علي
جرحا تمادى فيه واستعصى الدواء
وحاولوا ستره عنهم فيابى وفي الخلوات
يغلبني البكاء
وليهم اذا ودعت ظهري وبين جوانحي داء عياء
والابيات لاحمد مطر
عمر المهدي يقول ولما برزنا لتوديعهم بكوا
لؤلؤا وبكينا عقيقا اداروا علينا كؤوس
الفراق وهيهات من سكرها
النفيقا تولوا فاتبعتهم اجمعين فصاحوا
الغريق فصحت الحريق
ومشاركه ايضا من عبد الباسط يقول ولقد
لقيت الحادثات فما جرى دمعي كما اجراه يوم
فراقي
وعرفت ايام السرور فلم اجد كرجوع مشتاق
الى مشتاق
وهذه مشاركه من وسيم يقول ما كنت اعلم قبل
دفنك في الثرى ان الكواكب في التراب تغور
ومشاركه ايضا من طارق والابيات للصمه
القشيري يقول قفا وادعاء نجدا ومن حل
بالحمى وقل لنجد عندنا ان يودعا بنفس تلك
الارض ما اطيب الربا وما احسن المصطاف
والمتربع واذكر ايام الحمى ثم انثني على
كبدي من خشيه ان تصدعا فليست عشيات الحمى
برواجع اليك ولكن خلي عينيك تدمع
بهذه المشاركه اذا اصلوا معكم الى ختام
هذه الفقره اشكر لكم مشاركاتكم واذكركم
بان تضعوا اسم تاملات الجزيره عند نهايه
كل مشاركه
[موسيقى]
نشا عروه ابن حزام يتيما في كنف عمه فما
الذي اوصله الى حاله يقول فيها كان قطعه
علقت بجناحها على كبد من شده الخفقان
لقد احب ابنه عمه عفراء فلما شب وشبت ولحق
بالرجال ولحقت بالنساء قال له عمه هي
امراتك بعد حين وعاش عروه على هذا الامل
ولكن زوجه عمه راته فقيرا فوقفت في طريق
زواجه بابنتها فقال له عمه اذهب والتمس
رزقا واشترط عليه ثمانين ناقه مهرا وذلك
نزولا عند مشوره زوجته ذهب عروه الى اليمن
وفي غيبته جاء رجل موسر من الشام وخطب
عفراء فالحت امها على ابيها حتى قبل
وزوجها منه وحملها الرجل الى الشام
ثم عاد عروه بعد سنه ومعه مائه بعير فقال
له عمه لقد ماتت عفرى واخذه الى كوم حجاره
وقال هذا قبرها فظل عروه يتردد على المكان
اياما حتى اخبرته فتاه من الحي بالحقيقه
فجزع الرجل وتزود وانطلق الى الشام نزل
بزوج عفراء ضيفا دون ان يخبره بنسبه وفي
الصباح وضعوا عروه خاتمه في قعب اللبن
وطلب من الجاريه ان تدفع القعب الى عفراء
فلما شربت عفراء رات الخاتمه في القاع
فشهقت وعرفت ان الضيف الزائر هو عروه
وحان منهما لقاء فتشاكايا وبكى كل همه
ولما عاد الزوج عرفه عروه بنفسه فعزم
الزوج عليه ان يبقى فاصر عروه على الرحيل
ادرك الرجل زوج عفراء ان الحب اتلف عروه
والا شفاء له فوعده ان يطلق عفراء ولكن
عروه ابا حياء وكرما ورحل من فوره
وظل جسمه يهزل وينحل حتى صار جلدا على عظم
وعرج اصحابه به في الطريق على عراف
اليمامه ثم عراف نجد فما عرفا له دواء وما
مات عروه قبل ان يصل الى دياره وقبل موته
قال قصيدته التي عرف بها
خليل من عليا هلال بن عامر بصنعاء اعوج
اليوم وانتظراني متى تكشفاء عني القميصه
بينا بيضطر من عفراء يا فتياني اذا ترى يا
لحما قليلا واعظما بلين وقلبا دائم
الرجفاني على كبدي من حب عفراء قرحه
وعيناي من وجد بها تكفاني كان قطاه علقت
بجناحها على كبدي من شده الخفقان جعلت
لعراف اليمامه حكمه وعراف نجد انهما
شفياني فقالا نعم نشفي من الداء كله
وقاما مع العواد يبتدراني فما تركا من
عوذه يعرفانها ولا رقيه الا بها رقياني
وقالا شفاك الله والله ما لنا بما حملت
منك الضلوع يداني
تحملت من عفراء ما ليس لي به ولا للجبال
الراسيات يداني
[موسيقى]
كلما سافرت استحضر ابياتا للامام الشافعي
او تنسب له يقول فيها سافر تجد عوضا عما
تفارقهم سافر تجد عوضا عما تفارقهم وانصب
فان لذيذ العيش في النصب ابيات جميله يقول
فيها اني رايت وقوف الماء يفسده انساح طاب
وان لم يسري لم يطي بي والاسد لولا فراق
الارض ما افترست والسهم لولا فراق القوس
لم تصبي الى اخر هذه الابيات
فحين اردت السفر في المره الاخيره استحضرت
هذه الابيات وقلت
سافر تجد
سافرت لم اجد الا اشتياقا حام في كبدي كيف
التعلل يا معللتي ما لم يكن بالدار والولد
مالي ارى بلدي تنكر لي يا ليت شعري ما ذها
بلدي السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]